e aí galera campeonato bom você ea bom o
papa e bom hoje já começou o dia do
trabalho que grava em um lugar diferente
eu queria luiz do som e fez saber que a
janela só que essa janela aqui se eu
quiser a bela tem que do outro lado da
casa total voadora nela aí vou lá lá na
cama janela que é brincadeira né
não tá começando a copa do mundo já está
começando a copa do mundo e tem uma
coisa que eu não consigo entender na
internet é aquela pessoa que sai
comentou em qualquer coisa hashtag não
vai ter copa aqui
hashtag não vai ter copa já está tendo
um animal você chegar em junho de 2014
comentou que não vai ter copa e quando
chega na tua mãe mas mãe não vai ter
janta com um pedaço de frango na mão
gente protesta em 2007 2008 eu fico
imaginando crack comenta não vai ter
copa o que ele acha que está acontecendo
com ele comenta ele acha que a dilma
está no computador vamos ver no que se
refere a questões mulheres lactose daí
deixou dar uma olhada na página no bar
que o brasil exporta fortinho do irã a
não poder ser aquele acho que a dilma
vai tá duela no facebook vai ter este
teste não vai ter com o placar
[ __ ] josé clodoaldo da silva carvalho
está dizendo que não vai ter folga daqui
a pouco ela o galvão narrando o jogo da
seleção pampa pampa
a pressa de um colégio que se refere à
questão e infraestrutura no que se
refere à inversão de estado se refere em
questão de futebol não vai ter copa
valeu falou você é fã de protesto em
forma mais serena mas faz antes de
começar as obras não me importo com a
copa não me importa se o brasil vai
perder vai ganhar outra questão que
surgiu o seguinte no primeiro jogo da
copa do mundo bateu bem em cima do dia
dos namorados só queria aparecer um
monte de gente sempre vai comemorar o
dia dos namorados no dia 11 com que o
dia 12 e vai ter copa do mundo porque o
pilar do sul o jogador vou passar 24
horas jogando ou namorado não passar 24
horas podendo o que eu acho muito
difícil né
no que se refere à questão de rapidinho
né isso que eu não sei porque você tem
um problema e não sei
o problema gente pra que isso não é
porque é porque não vai dar tempo de ver
só o morro do bom
hoje é um dia muito especial eu estou
até emocionado no instrumento hoje é o
nosso primeiro dia dos namorados juntos
e presente há alguma coisa que é muito
importante pra mim
então hoje você vai jogar um primeiro
controle se deixar cair a menos meia
hora viu gente 30 se tem necessidade
comemorar no dia 11 porque no dia 12 a
copa a não ser que você tenha sido
convocado dia dos namorados que eu vou
tentar me afastar do facebook porque vão
aparecer fase do tipo solteira sim
sozinha nunca significa dá pra todo
mundo mas ninguém quer namorar por
motivos de dá pra todo mundo tem uma
dica para você arranjar namorado não dê
pra todo mundo aí vai aparecer frases do
tipo antes só do que mal acompanhado
significa ninguém me quer eu choro
sozinho escutando jorge bateu então
apareceu um monte mas um monte de menina
com foto bem editada na retranca para
tentar arranjar namorada minha filha é o
seguinte deus nem beleza você não é
retórica que vai deixar você bonita eu
pelo menos não vi muito bonita pelo
menos vou tentando dar um jeito ao longo
da vida também inclui maquiagem venceu
em beleza interior quer saber de você o
que você mais odeia no dia dos namorados
o que você come aqui embaixo que você
mais odeia na copa do mundo comenta aqui
embaixo saída não acredito que podia
sair desse vídeo não ia lá e te fazeres
clube em pleno dia dos namorados são
muito pode fazer coisas que não fazem
festa janela do teu cu london a equipa
nós que ajuda muito é a primeira vez que
estava no meu canal sic se inscrever em
outra coisa se você é de teresina sábado
agora dia 14 vai ter standard popular no
teatro da assembléia e na avenida
marechal e uma sessão às 6 horas e tem
outra sessão às 8 horas tem ingresso na
moral tatula no centro e no bairro
dirceu tem na radical modas e na play
roupa é só chegar e falar que o ingresso
e puxou muito vai ter do menino e do
windows ou de uns colegas se você é de
teresina você quer saber mais sobre o
standard é o primeiro link na descrição
do weekly como o primeiro link na
descrição do vídeo já
todas as informações e atira pra você lá
no facebook lembrando que a primeira vez
que vou apresentar esse meu texto já
presente em algumas partes pequenas pás
e outras vezes mas nunca presente ele
todo inteiro e é muito importante pra
mim que vocês que me assistem tv jam lá
pra me ver e talvez seja a única vez que
eu vá libertar em teresina vamos lá
vamos lá como lessa vão se divertir de
montão com essa turminha do barulho
lembrando que já temos lugar para depois
em oca a china no maranhão onde vai a
aracaju e são e então se você é de
teresina por favor vão dar aquela força
e tower palpite vai poder assistir esse
vídeo até aqui é nós